[Music]
oh hang on a moment I got to tweet to
get one of those free accounts
here all right I hope you all have
tweeted and gotten your your accounts in
I'm going to start a stopwatch there we
go so hello there I'm Rachel neighbors
and thank you for the lovely
introduction I used to be well I guess
technically I still am an award-winning
cartoonist I for many years made a comic
for website called girl.com and it was
specifically for teenage girls by
teenage girls and this little fellow
here that's my Alter Ego with the red
hair known as Rachel the Great and the
little fellow she's holding that's tuna
cats and I dare say he was the more
popular of the two and if I kept staying
in comics probably would have had his
own spin-off Series so I was making
Comics up until around 2007 I won an
award for best new female talent in the
industry and it was everything was
really cool but then life struck and I
had to get uh health insurance and you
know get a real job and all those things
and I was sad because one of my one of
my dreams was that one day my Comics
would be so popular I
would be able to have my own cartoon
based on them and I thought well you
know Ma that I'm in web development one
day maybe I'll learn flash and I'll make
that happen
well I kept putting off learning Flash
and learning Flash and and then I I
found out flash was not the thing to
learn anymore and said all right I'll
learn JavaScript I learn JavaScript I
was crazy about CSS always been a big
CSS nerd I know when people think of
front end developers they tend to think
of JavaScript developers and this makes
it really hard to interview for jobs by
the way just really hard but uh I was
looking at the css3 spec one day and I
uh I noticed that there was this this
this property I could use to actually
imitate key frames key frame animation
and that's when the madness started and
eventually led to my quitting my job and
traveling around at conferences and just
showing this Nifty thing eventually I'll
have to go get a real job again but for
now animation so let's start with a
couple of assumptions today what you're
going to be seeing we're using Chrome
these animations will work in all recent
browsers including IE 10ish and 11 uh IE
10's animations can be a little nity uh
we'll be using prefix free so if you
don't see prefixes it's precisely
because I'm using this handy script by
Le veru what it does is it goes into
your um what is it it detects what
browser your visitors are using goes
into your stylesheet uh scans it for
everything that needs a prefix and then
injects new prefix code into the head
it's really nice but I don't recommend
it for production animation or uh
production development at all because
about once out of every 30 or 40
refreshes the whole thing is borked so
it's much better if you're going to use
prefixes to go ahead and use like
compass with SASS and in that I have
actually made an extension called
Animation Studio which if you like the
techniques you see today this takes a
lot of the math out of
them so first off today I wanted to talk
to you a little bit about this is this
talk is super awesome because it's a
compilation of all of my best ofs from
every other workshop and talk I have
given in the past year and 3 months so
this is this is it you guys are going to
get it straight
on I'm going to talk to you about all
the different cool things that come
directly from animation that I've been
using and we're going to start with
storyboards now this is a picture I took
and I'm sorry about the glare they had a
lot of LCDs in this room but this is
from the Walt Disney Family Museum in
California and this is an example of one
of the world's very first storyboards
storyboards are a recent invention
back in the old days uh when Disney was
just making little shorts that played
before movies they would have a couple
of animators they go off into their own
rooms and they'd work on their things
separately and then they come back
together and it's like I've got a gag
I've got a gag and they'd stitch them
together and then they'd play that
before a movie and that was all very
well and good until they decided to work
on Snow White you couldn't have people
wandering off into their separate little
coding holes I'm sorry um animation
tables and working on individual
projects and then coming together
because you know this dance sequence
isn't going to flow into that dwarf
sequence at all so they invented
storyboards which were just
illustrations like this pinned to
corkboards that they could lift up and
haul over to another uh Studio plop down
and let new set of animators work on it
so anytime you needed to work with time
and talent it really
helped I like to think of it as
prototyping with the fourth dimension uh
that is the dimension of time so now
these storyboards are used not only in
animation but they're used in film
they're used in interaction design we
use them in comics anything that
involves times and teams it's a good
idea to bring out storyboard here's an
example of a storyboard I used for a
little music video which I use in an
example all the time as you can see I've
got the loading page and exactly what
happens when it's all Illustrated I even
if you click on it have a little
description and image to let people know
exactly what goes where I was the only
person on this team but I still found it
very useful to have all of this
information at my
fingertip and I'll actually show you
guys the music video This Is All by the
way CSS 3 animations and HTML 5
Audio hang
[Music]
on
and it just Loops like that forever I
know some
people
thank you guys so much so that animation
would not be possible without that
storyboard I showed you so they save you
time they help you figure out timing and
they give you a great overview of a
project so it's easy to make changes and
it helps you break a project down to
distribute amongst
teams so you notice the cat walking out
I'm sorry to say that I did not beat
rosan at being the first person to show
a cat today which is so sad because it's
all about the cat uh but anyway let me
show you how I got tuned to walk across
the the screen there this is something
that in animation we refer to as the
walk cycle and the walk cycle is oh darn
it that's not the right Ah that's not
the right
video I had this problem last night and
I thought I fixed it it's not being my
friend there it is sweet got
it so you see if you complain at the
computer long enough it does what you
want so walk Cycles are like the hello
world of Animation when kids go to
animation school they spend like their
first year working on a walk cycle and
they're really proud and excited about
it at first I didn't go to animation
school but I watched the suckers who did
and they get really proud and excited
about it and then two weeks in they're
like God why am I still doing this it's
insane it's like 24 frames just to get
this to
happen this is a walk cycle and it oh
God stupid escape button you're ruining
it so this is is a walk cycle of the
rather famous character Rogue from the
X-Men who watches the
X-Men woo and oh or reads the X-Men yeah
whatever all right so this is from the
series X-Men evolution which is a
cartoon based on a comic see bleed over
Comics turning into cartoons dreams
crushed and she's a character Rogue my
favorite character and she's designed by
this uh that walk cycle was done by
Master animator and character designer
Stephen K Gordon whose work you have
seen many many many times if you've ever
watched
cartoons he's a big fan of rotoscoping
oddly enough but that is some of his
work after you've done one of these you
you actually never want to do one again
and understand why so much animation
work is
outsourced it's simply not worth the
amount of time it takes a person in a
first world country to draw
this so here is how I made that happen
that's to he's walking it he's strutting
it yeah so what is going on under the
hood here as you can see I just have a
tuna div up
here there nothing nothing major special
going on there it's all down to the
animations let me see if I can make this
just a little bit prettier is that
that's legible all right so we've got a
key frames block down here now how many
of you have at least used a key frames
block at least once raise your hands
okay I I'll get into some depth for the
rest of you guys all right so CSS
animations work like this you define a
key frames
Block in this case we're using uh we're
calling it walk cycle and inside that
you define which properties you want it
to start with and which properties you
want it to end with in your 0% and 100%
locations you could also label them
start and finish or start and end
something like that I use 0% 100% cuz I
like working with num numers so in this
case we're just using a huge background
Sprite let me show it to
you yeah well we're only using this side
of the background Sprite you can see
that he's got the sitting animation you
saw me using earlier uh you can stack
these animations so that you can have
him go from walking to sitting and here
I've got one that goes between him
running and an actual running Sprite
over there which I use in a different
one which we'll probably look at in a
few so let's see where did I go here we
go no that's not it I'll show you that
later guys so anyway you'd find these
basically what we're doing is we're
repositioning the background straight
we're starting with it at 0 0 and then
we're jumping all the way down its
length now the magic is right here in
this little timing function called steps
usually when you define a uh an
animation it uses ease in it's a and you
get something like that which is how
very early animations were done
so so a little bit of Animation history
there but when we use steps what's
happening is that the timing function
instead of just you know starting at
Point a and moving everything to point B
it chops up those properties into in
this case 12 different stops and then it
hops between them so you get this lovely
smooth interaction well it looks smooth
because I've designed it to look smooth
you could make it look choppy uh I was
just talking with Anna and she turns out
that if you look at some of her examples
she uses steps to help add uh change
sizes and add elements to her cylinders
at the same time if you use something
like linear it would look very weird
while she was doing that so check out
those and look for the
steps and in case you want to see how
that works it's basically a name oh yeah
I should have probably shown you guys
the duration too yep so here's the name
this is the duration we want it to run
for 1 second and how many times we want
it to Loop we could just say happen once
and it would do that but I like him to
keep walking
forever we get to
you all right so cutouts this is the
best example of cutouts I could find
this is actually from a demonstration of
how Flash animation works but these are
different symbols or Sprites that are
being layered to create a face that has
eyes and a nose and a mouth and you can
change the mouth to give the illusion of
speech and there's some blinking eyes
and such and you composit them and you
get this this face that changes so
instead of having to draw that same face
a bajillion different times like we had
to back in the olden days of Steamboat
Willie where Mickey Mouse was moving in
every panel that's because every panel
was a new drawing they weren't doing
anything very economically back in those
days it wasn't until the 1960s that
people started making things using a
technique called cutouts it was a
pioneered by a company called Hannah
Barbara and it was originally developed
I think in Japan probably by Osamu tzika
a grandfather or or God of all Japanese
animation and I'm going to show you an
example of it I want you to keep an eye
on what parts of these animations are
moving and what parts aren't we're going
to skip ahead a little
bit this is bed
[Music]
all right it's working
it'sing and here's our chance Stone aged
transportation is highly Advanced with
the invention of the 4 engine jet fire
engine one fire
one all right here
comes here she comes Barney there's not
much moving in this look at how terrible
and jolty that was look at him go Barney
do you think that's safe Fred the only
part of that animation that that's
smooth is the movement of the mouth when
they had them actually turning and
looking you just see that the animators
were like oh this is like drawing a walk
cycle why am I working here so anyway by
just moving the mouth you're seeing a a
lot of uh you're saving a lot of time
there and you'll notice that most
characters from that era have like a
collar or something that chops off their
head and separates it from the rest of
their body so you can have a person
standing there and only their head is
moving but it doesn't look weird uh it's
you want to learn more about that
there's this really cool video out from
The Escapist called the importance of Lo
Yogi's collar which goes into great
depth and once you see it you will never
watch cartoons from your childhood again
quite the same
eyes so doing cutouts with CSS I'm going
to show you a
Sprite I blow it up so as you can see
this is the tuna from the end of that
music video he's got his little headset
on you cute face cute mouth right and
down here you can see he's got two
slightly different Expressions where
he's going to get lower Lids kind of go
from this happy open expression to kind
of a grinning yeah you know what I'm
talking about kind of
expression and these basically what I
did was I put a div over his face and
then I used the steps technique to flick
over those different
states come on you there there we go I
can show you exactly the code I use to
do
that yeah you got the wiggly
eyebrows good kitty so it's just an
expression nested in here and I couldn't
help but this morning when we were
talking about Shadow Dom elements I was
like yes I can finally clean up those
horrible horrible stringy divs inside my
animations just put a tuna on the page
and I can keep all that hidden and nice
and tidy I like that nobody will care
but I like
that so anyway down here here as you can
see it's the key frame smirk and the
numbers for this one are just a little
bit less pretty than the ones you saw
before because it is an irregularly
shaped Sprite and I have to do a little
bit of finagling to jump between it
without getting strange
loopiness
woot so scene
transitions this got to be somebody who
watches my little ponies in
here yay there we go Pinkie Pie all
right so she is obviously fighting what
we refer to as an iris wipe in
animations and again you're giving me
the wrong video guy yeah it'll come back
so
anyway scene transitions they're you'll
notice like when you're watching a
cartoon especially they're used a lot in
cartoons or in featurelength films
especially poorly directed ones seen
transitions are there to help patch over
when you're trying to move someone from
one frame of mind or point point of
reference into a different point of
reference for instance scene scene
transitions usually signify change in
thought uh narrative mood time or
location and I just wanted to show you a
cute little example of
one
hello an original scene transition
interesting they can be really
inventive that was from Ed Ed and any
which is I never watched but it's no
longer on TV it's still pretty good
though so I like to think of them as
like a a full stop uh between SP uh
sentences or like the space between
paragraphs it's a way of saying I have
finished with this idea and I'm starting
a new one please disregard what came
before but keep it in mind let's just go
on to another thing now this is actually
something I would like to see taken into
account with more in UI development I
know we use a lot of fade inss and fade
outs for user interfaces but if we
thought about it more like a director
thinks about using these transitions I
think we could come up with some more
powerful ways of dragging users out of
their current frame of rhyme which might
be like I'm editing a paper and into a
second frame of mind which is I'm
reading the paper to see if I got all my
edits incorrectly so instead of just
having like a I'm am typing in the word
processor save and then the page
completely blinks out to a new page
maybe it would be nice to fade out and
then fade in the new page like you're in
a different frame of mind now that's how
I would think about it so here's ex uh
here are a bunch of them I want you to
spot how many you can
see oh oh oh no it's not big enough hang
on I got to make it
bigger
oh what is oh no it won't let me log in
you're supposed to be in the gigantic
version fine come
here so there were a couple of Fade Out
outs and fade inss there uh we saw that
there was the iris wipe that zoomed in
on her and then we ended up switching
over to somebody else's point of view
and then we faded out so that we could
come back to our original character this
is a project called the black brick road
which the artist in inventor of is over
here her name is zeg she's Russian and
she's like she hasn't even graduated
from high school yet it's amazing I am
still not convinced that she's just not
some 42-year-old animation troll out
there trying to pull everyone's leg but
this was number 11 of her installment
and I drew this to kind of look like her
because I thought she was super cute and
I wanted to match I made this part down
here but the uh the rest of her cartoons
are really cool she basically draws
comics and has little interactive bits
and she'd been doing the interactive
bits in Flash and putting them on
devianart.com and I'd been following her
work and I was like hey would you like
to collaborate on something because I
see you're using a lot of Flash and I
could make something that you know it
could actually read on an iPad this does
look pretty good on an iPad by the way
it's pretty fun
um and she came back to me and she said
yeah I would love to do that um here
I've got this gigantic project you take
care of
it and I did and I'm really excited that
web apps are becoming more and and more
widely uh adopted Kindle Fire now
accepts web apps on their store which
means you can look forward to maybe
being able to buy the full version of
this as an as a Kindle Fire app one day
in the near future I would like that get
her some money for her efforts so anyway
enough showing off other people's work
it's my code it's her
art let's move on oh and basically for
that Wormhole you might be wondering how
how did I get that Iris swipe I bang my
head against that one for a long time I
got really sick of it so basically what
it is is I made this huge image and I
start it start with it scaled up so
large that the entire scene fits right
in here and then I just animate the
background round scale on it to make it
shrink to fit the entire thing and this
is all very carefully done so that as it
scales in this positions exactly over
her it's fairly simple but it's not the
sort of thing you think about doing
unless you had this particular use case
so let's talk Parallax Parallax it's so
popular right now but I think it's kind
of
overdone uh but that doesn't matter even
though I think it's overdone everyone
else is excited about it so I'm going to
tell you how it is this machine here is
called a what is it hang on a
minute a multiplan camera and it was
invented by OB ilks who actually was the
original animator of Mickey Mouse Walt
Disney actually did uh their Studios did
a lot of innovation for their time in
fact I would even say that the spirit of
Animation back during the Disney golden
years is not unlike the spirit we were
experiencing in front end development
today a lot of cool new things were made
one of the things they complained about
was when they were doing
scenes of like a a sweeping landscape
and they wanted to zoom in on a house or
something if there was a Sun or a moon
or a point of reference in the distance
as they zoomed in it got larger too in
reality when we look into the distance
the sun doesn't get bigger it stays the
same so they needed a way to imitate
this they needed a way for things in the
foreground to get bigger without things
in the background getting bigger too so
they could make those wonderful opening
scenes that you saw in uh in Bambi with
when you're moving through the forest it
actually looks like the forest is moving
around you or the the scene where Peter
Pan and Wendy are flying over London it
costs a small fortune to use this
basically what would happen is they put
the very very back background down here
and then they would put different panes
on top of it and each one of these was a
different sheet of glass that had
something painted on it and then they
would meticulously move each of these
there's a camera mounted up top and they
take a photo and they do this over and
over again of course you can do this in
Flash no bit no trouble at all these
days but back then then this was pretty
heavy stuff and they did a great job of
it and then during a hard times they
scraped off all the paint from those
glasses and well very few of the
backgrounds from Bambi exist to this day
but the interesting thing is that glass
discolors the paint so they had to use
very special paints that were
particularly keyed to be just bright
enough to offset that discoloration
depending on what uh what level the
glass was on
it was very mathy work so anyway let's
have a look at this in action because
I've been talking about it but I want to
show you what it's like I even got this
in German just for you guys it's The
Last
Unicorn this is all Parallax you can
feel the
[Music]
Majesty
love
hey you want to put this on your website
don't
you and now for some really obvious
examples you could tell they they
weren't quite ready to let go of The
Parallax
[Music]
yet so
much
[Music]
actually I totally lied I originally had
use the German version so people would
pay more attention to the parallx than
they would to the
dialogue but anyway you could tell that
in the foreground things were moving
slower in the background uh they're
moving a lot uh faster that is to give
the illusion of depth and I don't know
how many of you have been to the
mountains or you've seen like sweeping
mountainous Vistas in your life okay
it's something you probably notice from
taking a drive you'll notice like I was
raised in the Blue Ridge Mountains of
Virginia so I'm used to this scene where
you're driving in a car and the
mountains in the background are hardly
moving at all everything is racing past
around you and I did the same thing for
this particular animation I'll show you
the full the full version if I've got
the
time oh I might not so anyway as you can
see cat's walking up front and in the
background uh everything is moving at a
different rate this is simply you've got
a foreground here that's tuna I mean we
got the foreground of the grass running
in front of tuna we got the midr that
contains tuna that's him in the grass
right behind him and then there's the
background and the background is all
those mountains and as you can see let's
see background the background is just a
pile of different mountains layered on
top of each other and they're different
lengths and their background positions
all move over the same period of time I
run this Parallax BG frame over 40
seconds at
infinum let me show you a little diagram
of how this works there we go so as you
can see the things in the background
they're shorter so they take uh they
have less distance to go they waddle
along and the ones in the front have to
go faster to catch up reminds you of a
planet circling suns in that regard
there's some Physics
involved so let's see you can also do
this with 3D transforms I'm not going to
bother to show you guys that article
just yet
there's a really cool example of this
which I may show at the end but I
promised someone I was going to show my
version of Alice in Wonderland so let's
talk cushioning easing timing functions
you will hear these words thrown a lot
they are all exactly the same
thing uh in animation timing functions
when when we talk about css3 animations
and transitions we often talk about
timing functions or uh easing well in
animation that's always been called
cushion or I think one time slowing as
in slow in slow out uh ease in ease out
and here's an example of well you can
think of it this way when you drop a
ball it goes from slow to fast as it
increases its velocities it falls
towards the center of the Earth or
whatever the center of gravity on
wherever you're running the experiment
is happening uh when you think about
rolling a ball across the surface it
slows down because of friction taking
away its
momentum that is if you try to do any of
these animations using uh oh I'll show
you here's an example of a bouncing ball
animation where it doesn't start right
at
all that's linear linear easing oh my
[Music]
God little better
oh there that's that's some extreme uh
characterization
[Music]
there I I'm going to leave it on that
cuz that's funny
all right so there's a a really cool uh
article about applying that kind of
science to UI design and how you can
come up with a much more natural feeling
interface by keeping in mind that things
move in a certain way we're used to them
moving in a certain way and that kind of
subtle SKU amorphism it really does make
a difference in how well people relate
to a
product and I'm going to give you a
little example of this this is just
using transitions to roll a
ball as you can see it's slowing down
it's kind of natural right but I want
you to see how much more unnatural this
looks when I
change let's see ball ball ball come on
ball where did I put my
transitions feel like an old man all
right so that was a nice timing function
but if I change it to linear which just
starts at the same rate and ends at the
same rate looks very
unnatural
and you can even roll your own using
this uh there are many different kinds
of transitions but if you need a very
special kind you can roll your own using
cubic beer.com
I have actually had to use this from
time to
time all right
so before I show you show you my last
little set here so why it kicks ass I've
been talking to you a lot about these
things well number one it's familiar you
already have these tools you already
know how animate things your front end
developers you work with CSS all the
time there's nothing stopping you from
making things move and Shake in the
browser you don't need to learn action
script or anything like that CSS is
perfectly capable of most of the things
you're going to want to do and what I've
just shown you has helped these
techniques stick in your head better
than if I just showed you a bunch of uh
w3c specs which I'll be honest if I
hadn't been reading them it wouldn't
have occurred to me to do that but I
wouldn't want everyone to have to read
the full spec to realize what steps
exactly does
it's a lot of
fun and and lastly I'd like to think
that
the content is so much more than copy
the browser is not just a document
reader and right now we're doing all
sorts of things with web apps that
really stretch what browsers are capable
of and what they can be expected to do
this is why you really need to be paying
attention to the sorts of things that
you can animate and make move on the
screen it's not enough just to know
typography anymore you have to
understand motion design and interaction
you really do
so with these kinds of skills you can
build all kinds of uh of nifty little
things including I promised I was going
to show my version of aliceon video land
I mean aliceon Wonderland here it
is it's still in progress so you know
pardon if it looks weird it's just a
little something I'm working
on as you can see I I didn't bother to I
believe in showing the story instead of
telling the story Ros so um as you can
see much
Superior oh he's a very busy
rabbit oh no where is that bunny
going
Parallax I'm scrolling that
a
transition and she's not in Kansas
anymore so
anyway thank you guys for listening if
you'd like to know more about this I am
giving a master class workshop on these
animations in October you can find out
all about this and read these slides at
share. Rael nabors.com animation power I
and I am available for work and I hope
that I've inspired you to be doing more
with your user interfaces and spend more
time on perfecting those small
animations in the
[Applause]
future